hi T Welcome to our home
girl this is you
[Music]
I love you
okay shy we're gonna get ready for
school buddy no hold on brush your hair
okay
oh
my God
she's calling you shy to get ah
look here look at me
now now is this big jump you ready shy
you ready God it's time shut up we
good job here comes the other one
Don't Forget You party now shy you don't
have no diaper no you don't have a
diaper okay if you have to make a peepee
what do you think make sure you go to
the party shy if you have to make a pee
pee where do you go
in the body
gentlemen hey hey no fighting boys shy
what are you doing
hey no pushing him
boring shy
Boeing
okay watch his head you want potatoes
too boys
give me potatoes and zucchini
yay food shy shoes come on no you can't
play in there
all right
you don't want to see your friends
that's not nice shy
they want to see you
I should shoe come on
sit down and Ari's sleeping through all
of this
[Music]
that's it
y'all I love you see you later bye-bye
bye boys after we saw the chaos that is
the morning at Lauren and Alex's thank
you come to our place easy got an inside
look at the Cozy condo they call home
this is the Ari's room slash guest rooms
so there's a secret behind this room
tell us about it this was not here we
actually put this room up this wall was
the kitchen it was like a walk through
and we put a wall up and insulated it so
when the door is closed you can't hear
well insulated
does she sleep in here yet she does
sleep in here she sleeps in her crib
it's a little bit of a mess right now
but yeah she has her selfie mirror
outfit of the day mirror already like
Mommy oh yes and just outside little
Ari's room there's this favorite couch
yes wait right here this is the first
one the big one yeah Alex can fit on it
it was also his bed finally fit on the
couch from tall people problems trust me
I understand so the struggles of keeping
a tidy house with three kids under three
okay now we have the boys room
[Music]
should have made their beds but you know
that was I was gonna ask you that do you
with cameras always in here do you feel
the need to always have your place tidy
but I'm always like that without cameras
like I have to make my bed every morning
well yeah that's good that's a good
habit I shouldn't make fairies and then
we have our family photo here we don't
like the pictures
adorable and they have a nice closet
they have their selfie mirror too
cute and the sneakers
Air Forces oh yeah all right let's go to
your room yes our room is a mess
this is where the magic happens and
pillow talk right yeah
but the duvet is being washed right now
yeah the cover is worse we also don't
have a theme for our room it just is
what's your favorite part about this
room if you I love you yeah my favorite
part is probably the closet oh yeah oh
yeah I feel like that's its own separate
room oh yeah yeah
this is my favorite room I worked very
hard to organize it as much as they
could why is it this is it your closet
why is this bigger closet it should be
out in the front so everyone can see
yeah no we have to give it its own shelf
so yeah with the reminder like we really
love each other reality romance we're
real yeah he's not romantic but we love
each other I love that
this is where I pose
Alex get on in there oh let's take a
selfie we should oh that's cool we're
going to be behind you on the sides like
this
[Music]